good morning John this is a special
bonus video not in response to your last
video but in response to my last video
because I said something that didn't
make any sense I said that the majority
of Muslims live in Asia not in the
Middle East and the reason why this
doesn't make any sense is because the
majority of the Middle East is in fact
in Asia now highpoint plays out if you
subtract the population of the Middle
East from the population of Asia there
many more Muslims in Asia than there are
in the Middle East the real problem with
that statement is that Asia is most
people like most of everyone lives in
Asia more than half of the world's
people now I was thinking about this
what happened in my head is the entire
concept of a continent broke down and
went away so we are taught in America
anyway I don't know what everybody else
is taught that there are seven
continents there's North America South
America Europe Asia Australia Africa and
why Antarctica the one everybody forgets
cuz nobody lives there - the people who
are currently on Antarctica I apologize
for saying no one lives there but let's
be honest what a continent is is
supposed to be any like large contiguous
area of land that is defined by ocean
borders this works fairly well for North
and South America and Africa it kind of
breaks down everywhere else that kind of
breaks down foreigner that says America
which aren't deep connected to each
other and for Africa which is connected
to Asia and I guess it makes sense for
Australia but is it just a really big
island or is it really tiny continent I
don't know and then it arctica don't get
me started its an archipelago under the
ice and the biggest island in the
archipelago is smaller than Australia
and then you have the elephant in the
room Europe and Asia which are clearly
by any geographical definition the same
continent the only reason Europe is a
separate continent is because I was
taught by people who are culturally
European and they wanted it to be but if
there's any part of the definition of a
continent that is cultural then there is
no excuse for one continent containing
Russia and Indonesia and Japan and China
and the Middle East in India and
Pakistan what this is exacerbated in my
world by the commonality of the Mercator
projection map which makes lots of
things that are very big look tiny
example
I was talking about how the majority of
Muslims lived in Indonesia and that just
seemed impossible to me because
Indonesia in my head is very small but
then you drag it on up from the Mercator
projection and if it was in the same
place as Europe it's pitched huge it
stretches all the way from North Ireland
to frickin Kazakhstan Indonesia has the
same land area as the UK Germany France
Spain and Italy combined
what's my solution do I think that
Europe and Asia should be one continent
or that Europe and Asia and Africa
should be one continent and North and
South America should be one continent
and then maybe Australia and in our
garden park our car to Tahoe not really
I think that continents are a useful
idea in grade school when you're
introducing children to the idea that
the rest of the world exists but for
adult humans I think that it's time that
we move past this massive
oversimplification that leads to
lifelong misunderstandings of reality
and discard the entire concept of the
continent John you will see me tomorrow
with my video about the global goals
which I am very excited to share
everybody go to global those org if you
haven't done that already so you can you
gotta study up a little bit before that
video because you're gonna want to know
yeah you're gonna want to know
you'll see my collection on pillow
give me the panini I'm a long-term
friend and supporter of the nose I'm
gonna played on one of these can either
play on this later
yes your thing what a fine-looking horse
she is you know what Jimmy I don't know
if I agree how dare you love her the
Sawyer's Oh Charlie look there's Christ
that's science right there I think it's
adorable in a way would you date it No